are you ready
okay good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
welcome to brooklyn wisconsin we're
about to start the competition here
today and anytime you guys are ready to
pull while you go ahead and pull and
never mind me
[Music]
tug of war is the ultimate team sport
if one man goes down
he can take the whole team down with him
because you have to have eight pullers
working in unison as one
to the general public they think tug of
war may be just a game in high school
keep it low
in serious competition their strict
rules and guidelines and only the top
athletes in the countries get to that
level
[Applause]
if you're going into a rope pull you
might be the strongest person in the
world but if your head isn't in it
you're going to lose
man
keep fainting position scott there you
go there you go
[Music]
ah good job guys
your legs are the strongest muscles in
your body and they can push 400 pounds
easy and you got to transfer that
through your hands they're not allowed
to wear gloves they can only put the
tack on calluses build up i call them
square fingers because you got you get
the edges pushed i got involved with tug
of war when i was drunk i was
at a softball tournament and a friend of
mine from high school said they were
short and needed an extra puller and i
said okay i've been pulling ever since
try it again
shut well the reason that tug of war was
ousted from the olympics is that they
were cutting sports so they dropped it
and that's been the fight to get it back
in
i hope to see it back in the olympics
because i believe it deserves to be
there i'm representing the us
and i take a lot of pride in trying to
do the best job i possibly can